[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti a tutti Oggi vorrei
partire con una riflessione su un verbo
il verbo guarire Il 5 maggio di
quest'anno l'organizzazione Mondiale
della sanità ha dichiarato la fine
dell'emergenza pandemica da covid-19
abbiamo attraversato tre anni di grandi
incertezze di drastici cambiamenti della
nostra quotidianità e soprattutto nelle
nostre vite si sono insidiate delle
nuove paure dopo questi tre anni siamo
riusciti a ritornare alla nostra
precedente caoticità anche grazie alla
ricerca scientifica le precauzioni al
senso e al buon senso civico ma occorre
Chiederci quando guariremo dal virus
della solitudine
uno studio del 2020 del Sole 24 Ore ha
dimostrato che oltre la metà della
popolazione italiana soffre di di
solitudine e in particolar modo il 18%
dichiara di soffrirne spesso il 37 a
volte e di questi il 70% è fatto da
giovani nella fascia 18-34 anni
e un altro grande virus da cui dovremmo
guarire è quello dell'egoismo e della
violenza in quanto questa tendenza nella
società a diventare sempre più individui
sempre più atomi porta anche a delle
guerre come non si vedevano nella nostra
Europa da una centuria E questo ci deve
far riflettere perché penso che per
guarire c'è un grandissimo strumento che
quello della Cultura e in quanto la
cultura ti permette di andare oltre e di
riuscire a entrare in connessione con il
mondo che ti circonda e con l'altro ma
questo ce lo spiega meglio di me
sicuramente una poesia di Emily
Dickinson che ho provato a
ad analizzare e analizzeremo insieme a
voi un senso esagerato e assegnato al
cibo da chi ha fame
se gli è lontano lui sospira Dunque è
impossibile Dunque è buono
procurarselo senz'altro conforta ma ci
dimostra che il gusto nella ricetta
evapora era la distanza il suo sapore
dice Emily Dickinson e penso che lo
scopo è ciò che la cultura permette di
rivelare nella nostra vita è proprio
questo Cioè una vita tendenzialmente
vissuta guardando le mattonelle che
pestare i nostri piedi senza riuscire ad
alzare la testa e a guardare invece il
mondo che ci circonda è una vita
miserevole triste e avere invece uno
strumento che può essere un libro
guardare un film andare a teatro ti
permette di riuscire ad allargare la
prospettiva dell'orizzonte avere una
distanza e quindi gusto e quindi
recuperare una dimensione autentica
della propria esistenza che si scopre
inevitabilmente in connessione con tutto
ciò che la circonda
nel 1932 un grandissimo filosofo e
scrittore britannico chiamato Aldo
saxley scrive una delle più grandi
distopie del Novecento sono tre le più
famose Le altre le conosciamo forse
quasi tutti 1984 e Fahrenheit 451 di
autori diversi Aldo sax e scrive il
mondo nuovo nel titolo originale o brave
World che è una citazione tratta dalla
Tempesta di Shakespeare la distopia è un
romanzo che di per sé un genere
letterario che tendenzialmente Proietta
la società in un Futura abbastanza
lontano enfatizzando degli elementi
fantascientifici e soprattutto creando
una sorta di caricatura anche satirica
di comportamenti umani che in qualche
modo nel presente in cui gli autori lo
scrivono si rivela In ogni caso e nel
mondo nuovo di Axel è ambientato nella
Londra del 2500 Anche se questa data non
esiste più perché gli anni non si
contano dalla nascita di Cristo ma dalla
scoperta di Henry Ford della macchina a
forma di T Henry Ford e in qualche modo
il Dio di questa società
i soggetti Vivono in una in una maniera
totalmente diversa rispetto alla nostra
già soltanto dalla fecondazione non c'è
più la fecondazione vivipara c'è la
fecondazione in vitro quindi gli esseri
umani nascono in delle bocce in degli
appositi centri per la natalità dove sin
dalla nascita viene attribuito a ogni
feto Lo scopo della sua vita e quindi
Esistono delle classi sociali Alfa beta
gamma e Delta gli Alpha sono i grandi
capi coloro che hanno delle posizioni di
responsabilità e i delta sono coloro che
invece fanno le mansioni più umili e in
questo i soggetti non possono
riscattarsi perché questa condizione
viene attribuita dalla nascita e rimarrà
fino alla fine della loro vita che
Sostanzialmente è già prefissata 60 anni
a 60 anni uno si accinge in un centro
apposito dove con un'iniezione muore
perché perché la vecchiaia è sofferenza
e nel mondo nuovo non si può soffrire
L'unico obiettivo è la felicità il
piacere continua e perpetuo un piacere
che Sostanzialmente è una sorta di
dubbio dalla quale i cittadini del mondo
nuovo non riescono a svegliarsi perché
non hanno gli strumenti per farlo e
direi che Axl lo spiega bene la ragione
di questa delle ragioni di questa
sonnolenza che per vari cittadini del
mondo nuovo mancano i libri I libri sono
proibiti anche in Fahrenheit D'altronde
torna un po' questo motivo dei libri che
vengono bruciati nel mondo nuovo non ci
sono proprio il mondo è diviso in 10
grandi aree con 10 governatori mondiali
e soltanto a questi è concesso di
detenere nelle loro cassaforti qualche
copia di Shakespeare o della Bibbia a
tutti gli altri no E in questo contesto
nel romanzo del mondo nuovo ci abbiamo
due personaggi da una parte Bernard Marx
che è un Alfa innamorato di una donna
che si chiama lenina e i nomi sono
profondamente parlanti in questo romanzo
che era un'Alfa di gran che aveva grandi
responsabilità Ma che viveva una sorta
di frustrazione interiore che non
riusciva a giustificarsi e dall'altra
parte John un uomo che viene dalla
riserva in Messico infatti vi è un'area
geografica dove gli esseri umani vivono
Come si viveva prima della rivoluzione e
quindi si accoppiano in maniera vivipara
muoiono di morte naturale o di malattia
invecchiano soffrono E hanno anche delle
relazioni perché nel mondo nuovo ad
esempio il legame di coppia coniugale o
perpetuo viene totalmente
disgustato nell'opinione pubblica tanto
che chi ha delle relazioni continue con
una certa persona viene additato e
accusato dagli altri come se fosse un
diverso di questa diversità non ne
apprezzano sicuramente la specialità
e il nostro John quest'uomo che viene
dalla riserva del Messico dimostrerà
come
questo mondo è caducevole e appena
arriverà a Londra dal Messico in realtà
lui esordirà con una una forma di
stupore dirà Oh Gray World citando
Shakespeare dando poi il titolo a questo
romanzo o Mondo nuovo che creature
meravigliose che contiene Ma poi Axel di
mostrerà che tanta meraviglia in realtà
non c'è e Spero che possiate leggere
questo libro per capire poi cosa
succederà nella trama che non voglio
assolutamente spoilerare ma nel mondo
nuovo c'è un'altra caratteristica
importante che se lo Stato proibisce i
libri dall'altra parte distribuisce
gratuitamente a tutti una droga che si
chiama Soma e non è un caso che la
questa droga riporti il termine greco
del corpo perché è un mondo
sostanzialmente accorato alla materia
che si dimostra però profonda importante
caducevole infingarde traditrice e
invece viene esclusa qualsiasi
possibilità di apertura allo spirito
all'intelletto e la cultura in questo
axley ci dimostra che è pericolosa e
pericolosa sicuramente perché da una
parte su un piano politico rendi i
cittadini più consapevoli più critici e
in questo è una minaccia ai poteri
centrali che invece vorrebbero
rassicurarsi di effettuare il loro
lavoro senza grossi disturbi e
dall'altra parte è scomoda per noi
stessi perché quando ci approcciamo a un
testo o ascoltiamo possiamo anche
accorgerci che tante cose che abbiamo
costruito nella nostra vita in realtà
perdono di spessore che tante paure che
abbiamo soppresso in realtà emergono nei
momenti più fragili e non sappiamo
affrontarle non sappiamo approcciarci
perché poi la cultura da anche questo
un'educazione
prospettiva che è necessaria per
riuscire ad avere una tridimensionalità
nella propria esistenza ma nel nostro
paese soprattutto ed è uno studio
dell'instart dello scorso anno riferito
al 2021 l'abitudine di leggere almeno un
libro nella nell'anno è molto bassa la
media si attesta intorno al
40,8%, e scende soprattutto al sud dove
siamo poco di più del 29%, perché c'è
anche una certa ostilità nei confronti
dell'oggetto libro che è molto spesso
viene visto in maniera quasi superflua
come se non fosse una necessaria età o
anche come uno un dispendio economico e
non è un caso che soprattutto nel
mezzogiorno o nelle nelle zone più
Periferiche In alcune zone periferiche
del nostro paese la presenza delle
librerie delle librerie sia molto rara e
tra due Paesi diversi occorre fare
diversa strada per raggiungere una
libreria che li possa connettere
e la connessione importante perché penso
che la cultura abbia proprio questo
valore cioè quello di essere collante
delle comunità e da questo valore
imprescindibile non possiamo farne a
meno c'era un fisico svedese che si
chiamava Oscar Clarine che provo a
teorizzare la quinta dimensione e
intellettualmente anche nel Mestre
Margherita di Michael bulgakov compare
questa dimensione la quinta dimensione
compare in un momento quando prima del
gran ballo Margherita si ritrova a
vedere una stanza a diventare un salone
da ballo per effetto della compagine del
diavolo Il Maestro e Margherita forse la
storia d'amore più bella mai scritta di
sempre ma questa è una mia opinione e
quando chiede come è possibile si sente
rispondere la quinta dimensione cioè
quella della coscienza
ci chiediamo mai se la coscienza
effettivamente non sia relegata a delle
supposizioni teoriche ma abbia anche
degli effetti nella nostra realtà avere
una coscienza critica avere una
coscienza partecipe sveglia vigile
riuscire a dotarsi di esperienze
culturali nella propria vita permette
proprio questo di essere consapevoli e
la consapevolezza rende vigili e solo
essendo vigili possiamo instaurare delle
relazioni col mondo che ci circonda che
siano positive e che soprattutto abbiano
degli effetti anche rivoluzionari
nel nostro contesto sociale la domanda
se siamo pronti a questo
se la poneva benissimo in una poesia
anche nell'i sax che in realtà è una
grandissima poetessa e la poesia Non può
essere incanalata in un'unica
interpretazione Ma io vi ho dato questa
e la porto qui oggi
nel sax scriveva se i profeti
irrompessero per le porte della notte
incidendo ferite di parole nei campi
della consuetudine se i profeti
rompessero per la porta della notte e
cercassero un orecchio come Patria
orecchio degli uomini ostruito d'ortica
sapresti ascoltare
Ecco ora occorre che ciascuno di noi si
chieda noi donne e uomini del 2023
vogliamo essere i cittadini del mondo
nuovo un mondo come quello di Axel dove
sicuramente c'è un progresso tecnologico
dove sicuramente ci si può si può
spostare volando dove ci sono delle
innovazioni che appena le vedi un essere
umano comune dice Oh brave World o Mondo
nuovo mondo meraviglioso
ma un mondo dove le nostre orecchie sono
ostruite d'ortica e dove dilagano i
virus della solitudine e i virus
dell'egoismo e della violenza dove
sostanzialmente diventiamo atomi e non
riusciamo a smostare a smuovere la testa
dalle mattonelle che calpestiamo e
riuscire ad accorgerci che c'è una
distanza che va oltre la limite della
nostra vita e che dà gusto alla nostra
esistenza come Emily Dickinson Oppure
vogliamo essere donne e uomini con
queste caratteristiche con il sacrificio
anche di affiancarsi esperienze
culturali e a viverle e probabilmente
anche a rivoluzionare la propria vita ma
Pronti al cambiamento e soprattutto
protagonisti solidali di questa vita
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]